wenn ich hier den daumen drauf
warum spiele ich diese spiele ich kann
nicht mal ein stein auf dem blog
schmeißen
hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft ja ihr habt richtig erraten
mannschaft jetzt heute was bleibe ich
hier ich habe mir mal wieder ein command
rausgesucht und zwar von den stamm ein
crafting käme ja schon von partnern
kommen
er hat auf jeden fall drauf leschke
command unterstrich blockbuster bekommt
man schon command blockieren schönleber
packen das ganze hier schön hin fügen
den koran eindrücken auf den schalter
und bekommen
richtig da du diese scheiß kühe immer
näher ich werde ja nicht mehr mit diesem
da da seht dann guckt euch an wir haben
hier die maschine kriegen wir haben hier
alles voll mit kühen hier vorne ist auch
noch seine christian hinten und noch
mehr kühe ich werde ja nicht mehr ja
überall sind die mittlerweile hier
hinten auch nur noch kür sehe ich hier
am start dann wäre es ja jetzt auch wenn
neben der hort und der heute noch den
ordner sind den punkt den ich euch heute
zeigen möchte ist der herr hölle
minecraft neuer schwierigkeitsgrad
command ja wurde uns ist diese maschine
hier gebaut da drücken wir von links
drauf und items bekomme ich kein bock
auf das ganze in vogel aber wir haben
auf jeden fall ein paar alterns am start
können die 3
iron blöcke hinsetzen und mir
beispielsweise man redstone bloggt auf
dann bekommen wir nämlich den destroyer
hier schmeiß dich mal ein gold in goch
drauf da bekommen wir den stabilizer und
wenn ich hier den daumen drauf schmal
warum schwierig diese spiele ich kann
nicht nur ein stein auf dem blog
schmeißen ich schmeiß die den diamanten
drauf und bekomme einen restore zwar
gilt natürlich was können die destroyer
ist wenn ich den hinsetze kommt die
hölle restora wenn ich den hinsetze
verschwindet die wieder und stabilizer
da verschwindet die hölle für fünf
minuten temporär sag ich mal diese items
hier brauchen wir eigentlich erst mal
nicht mehr was wir allerdings definitiv
brauchen werden ist ein diamant schwert
und auf jeden fall komplette diamant
rüstung denn meine damen und herren die
hölle ist auf jeden fall kein place den
man einfach so ganz klein fröschen 1
überwinden kann wenn ich jetzt einfach
nach diesen destroyer hier auf den boden
rammen seht ihr schon ein blog gibt nach
unten gelegt die nach unten und einen
block geht nach oben und alles gut jetzt
tritt überall so ein bisschen rauch auf
wo wir hinschauen und das deutet jetzt
quasi an dass sich alles immer mehr in
die richtung kommt in die hölle
verbunden was jetzt genau gerade
passiert ist dass alle mops werden
schneller allem ochs können mehr schaden
einstecken sage ich mal allerdings alle
mops bis auf zombies bei zombies ist es
nicht so die können schon wieder ne kuh
hallo was geht wenn ich hier ziemlich
einfach mal ein paar zombies sind sätze
wie ihr schon die tränen nicht am tag
und die vom biss und langsamer als sonst
im vergleich beispielsweise zu kühlen
die relativ schnell sind aber meine
kurse zum deswegen machen wenn nicht ein
zombie angreife
ich sollte vielleicht aus dem game ort
rausgehen game mode 0 dann seht ihr
schon mich greift da schon der erste
zombie an und wenn ich den jetzt einfach
mal boxe und jetzt theoretisch auch ihr
seht schon der steckt vielmehr einen
jeden moment müsste der zombie aber auch
gleich sein und dann wirklich schon
jetzt ist nämlich anderen eine kleine oh
mein gott eine kleine chance dass hinter
dem das aus dem die kleinen hier raus
sitzen das sind nämlich reisen riesen
halten wie die sind als schwächer als
zombie als ihre größeren brüder
allerdings sind sie schneller und wenn
man von genen die tötet dann haben die
ich bin nicht ich bin schlecht ich kann
mich nicht auf zwei sachen gleichzeitig
konzentrieren ich spaß
ich kann die nicht täglich mit viel zu
schlecht auer ich in ruhe wenn ich die
jedenfalls führte gibt es auch eine
chance dass die wieder auch wieder diese
reisen droppen dann attackieren die mich
wieder das heißt es ist quasi schier
unmöglich alles zu töten es ist
allerdings möglich wenn ich mir bommel
holen dafür gehe ich wieder mal ganz
kurz in game und 1 und hole mir hier
oben ein wenig bei mir weil wenn ich
dann bauen wir auf diese kleinen
vollpfosten drauf schmeiße versinken die
quasi wieder im erdboden und eben zurück
für ihr da wo sie hingehören da hinten
kommt jetzt nämlich der kleine
angelaufen und ich weiß jetzt bauen wir
auf ihn
hab da gehört das war's jetzt allerdings
auch schon mit den zombies was wir uns
allerdings als nächstes anschauen sind
skelette und es war wenig skelette
hinsetzte spawnen die immer mit einer
eisen rüstung und sind ebenfalls stärker
sie haben halt quasi die attribute wie
zombies nur dass sie im gegensatz zu den
zombies schneller sind die haben nicht
die bessere rüstung halten
dementsprechend auch hier raus also
normalerweise skaten und ja man schlage
die wären eigentlich schon längst tot
und was dieses glätte auch haben ist
wenn ich einfach mit den gamern null
gehe die können mich abschießen die
pfeile sind halt viel stärker also wenn
die mich treffen seht ihr schon mal
männer rüstung
wenn die mich mal treffen würden ist
aber auch egal wenn die zu dumm sind
nicht zutreffen kann ich euch ja das
andere erst mal zeigen wenn der fall
nämlich daran vorbei fliegt es bietet
sich der pfeil auf da habt ihr es
gesehen ist ihr verschiedene pendant war
schon wieder der files findet sich in
mehrere verschiedene pfeile wenn er
nicht trifft das heißt wenn er jetzt
einfach mal neben schießen würde dann
ist das vielleicht noch mal richtig
machen so dass sich das zeigen kann wie
du da da darf ist kurz gesehen ist es
müssen sich halt in die einzelne pfeile
auf die die gleiche kraft haben und ist
auf jeden fall hat scheiße was sie jetzt
da unten schon seht heißt es hell und
man denkt jetzt erst mal okay was soll
das das sollte eigentlich erst später
kommen aber dadurch dass ich halt gerade
schon bei minute acht eigentlich schon
bin normalerweise kommen fünf minuten
nachdem andy
der hölle kreiert hat diese meldung man
hört komische sound und diese leute
kommen das sind zins und diese zu töten
ist eigentlich nahezu unmöglich ihr seht
schon was hinter sich herziehen das sind
nette reck die verwandeln die mich die
hölle
die normale welt immer mehr in die hölle
und wollen jetzt ein bisschen netter
dazu warum sterbe ich denn jetzt gerade
das sind quasi modifizierte river
skelette die sind unglaublich stark die
haben übel viel gesundheit es ist
eigentlich nahezu unmöglich zu besiegen
und wenn man nicht eine diamant rüstung
hat und im diamant schwert besitzt ist
es eigentlich auch unmöglich und jetzt
gerade und wenn man auch luca heißt es
ist eigentlich auch noch mal komplett
unmöglich ist fakt mich ab der baut sich
einfach die ganze zeit mit navteq
vordermann kann die zwar besiegen das
ist klar dafür brauchen wir allerdings
ein gewisses schwert das zeige ich euch
jetzt gleich mal allerdings kommt es zum
stable item das kann ich einfach jetzt
auf den boden setzen und wenn ihr auf
den zehen achtet der 10
ich weiß deutschen türken aber wir
können darüber reden wenn die stage
sonst noch so langsam sollte er
tatsächlich auch mal verschwinden was
eigentlich passiert wenn ich den stempel
in den boden rammen ist es dass quasi
alles so ein bisschen wieder normal wird
für fünf minuten was hier gerade alles
scheiße und wie das christentum
das ganze passiert jetzt gerade nicht
ich finde es ehrlich gesagt ein wenig
traurig dass das ganze doch es ist
gerade passiert ihr seht hier der ist
jetzt nach unten wurde jetzt quasi
reingezogen werden fünften erstmal der
ruhe heim set 0 damit sie mal wieder ein
bisschen hell ist hier haben wir jetzt
haben nämlich auch schon was das wetter
macht also wenn es einem zu viel wird
kann man einfach nur den stempel eisern
rausholen denen man quasi mit einem gold
award und den eisen blog verhaftet dann
hat man erst mal ruhen denkt sich zwar
auch hier wenig ruhe haben will wenn du
dich einfach den die story an weil dann
ist es komplett alles weg die ganze
halle allerdings kostet die stange
halten
diamond und den eisen blog deswegen das
ist natürlich schon mal ein stückchen
teurer haben wir jetzt allerdings erst
mal zu einem anderen mob dienst
natürlich auch noch gibt die wir
natürlich nicht vergessen dürfen nämlich
den krieg aber wenn ich mich hinsetze
denkt man sich erstmal okay das ist
jetzt am keeper anders wenn ich dann
allerdings in den gärten null gehe seht
ihr schon ich gehe zum creeper hin box
mit dem probleme reden der keeper ist ja
jemand der hat so die schon relativ viel
zu tun in seinem leben und dann legt er
sich natürlich noch auch wenn ich den
lukas dann brauche ich mich viermal zum
zwischen sondern ich mach das einfach
einmal und hau einfachen zehnfachen
krater hier eigentlich was der kleber
halt macht ist er ist viel stärker
geworden er macht einfach ihr seht ja
schon nach den riesigen krater anrichten
kann und
lässt sich keine zeit sondern explodiert
einfach direkt luca du hast doch ein
buch über mein schrift geschrieben was
macht man denn jetzt wenn man so ein
creeper besiegen will richtig freunde
der sonne wenn ich den creeper da hinten
sehen würde würde ich einen pfeil und
bogen schnappen und den einfach da unten
ist die krieger kann man hier wirklich
am besten mit pfeil und bogen einfach
attackieren so erhalten die den nötigen
abstand weil die explodieren ja direkt
wenn sie bei euch sind und dann kann man
die auch nachher zeit auf jeden fall da
haben wir ihn getötet meine damen und
herren da können wir schon die
erfahrungen sammeln das sind die kripo
auf die ich noch eingehen wollte dann
haben wir hier auf jeden fall auch noch
die killer häschen die sind und dann
kommen wir jetzt auch zum letzten lauf
den ich eigentlich zeigen wollte bevor
ich gedacht hatte
dies hält kommt was aber trotzdem
relativ schnell kamen weil ich so lange
wieder für dieses video gebraucht habe
ich bin allein jetzt schon bei einer
viertelstunde mir kommen zu den spinnen
ich hasse spinnen wenn ich eine spinne
hinsetze seht ihr schon auf sie schießt
spinnennetze drum herum um sich selbst
das heißt einfach sie will damit quasi
ihre beute so ein bisschen einfangen und
sie damit ja langsam machen und wenn ich
jetzt eine spinne angreifer seht ihr
auch schon die spinne ist unglaublich
schnell
hasselt da ist in die höhle reingefallen
die spinnen hier sind unfassbar schnell
ihr ahnt es wirklich nicht ihr könnt zum
beispiel von glück reden wenn sie
einfach mal selbst in
der block drin steckt das ist dann
natürlich wieder der vfb aber ihr seht
schon längst die spiele hatte sich auf
jeden fall einen ganz guten weg hin zu
recht schwer sich einen dem spinnen
polaczek und ich kann die irgendwann
auch töten so viel zu der spinne da ich
euch ja das ganze mit den zins da hinten
schon gezeigt habe dass ist das auch
jetzt kommen die schon wieder ich glaube
es ja wohl nicht das sind ja diese leute
mit den komischen netter rex hier und
das will ich euch aber gar nicht noch
mal zeigen sondern ich zeige euch
einfach mal was passiert wenn ein mieter
über diesen es alex drüber läuft also
ich schubse der fall da drauf und er
explodiert direkt ich hätte ja wissen
müssen ich zeig doch mal ein bisschen
anders ich jetzt hier in kuba hingehe
ok dann machen was so hier haben wir
jetzt nimmt der sind kannst du gehst
gefälligst von dem creeper weg danke
sind du bist aber nicht im club grad du
kannst auch mit einem komischen rolle
wir haben nach vorne einen
elektrifizierten krippenstein ihr fragt
euch jetzt natürlich was soll das ist
das einfach ein elektrisiert vier väter
trieb an ein lautes ja minecraft heißt
dieser krippe kuiper ja er hat einfach
mehr ist ein geparktes fahrzeug das in
der tripada unsere scheiß frisur hat das
ist ein schwert das ist das sort of the
undead und wenn ich das haben will muss
ich den krieg wieder mit pfeil und bogen
abschließen weil wenn ich ihm zu nahe
komme und ihn mit diamant schwert
abschlagen will dann ist es halt wieder
so dass er quasi direkt abonniert
deswegen muss ich ein bisschen abstand
halten und ihr seht schon er hat mir das
geile schwert hierhin gedruckt und wenn
ich das mal nehme wie die russin mit
wenn ich euch jetzt mal das schwert hier
zeigen seht ihr schon und ich gehe jetzt
mal wieder
ja ich traue mich das und wenn ich jetzt
so einen zehn mal angreifen sollte wenn
sich da in einer billa oder kommen
welche dann wäre ich schon kann ich mit
dem schwert einfach auf die draufgehen
und die auf jeden fall deutlich
einfacher attackieren und auch
irgendwann da haben wir den ersten
getötet haben der baut sich einfach in
mich rein der blöder pizza und da haben
wir auch schon dann jeden moment hier
den
aber jetzt haben wir tatsächlich auch
ganz schön viele sind sie gerade am
start ich fall auch gerade immer weiter
in ein loch rein das ist natürlich auch
sehr schön die das sind hier vorne steht
einfach mal im netz blog den kann man
auch mal schlagen bis erst war sie
direkt gegen moment spielt dann hätte
ich ja auch einfach mal eben schnell weg
einfach mal um zu zeigen wie viel diese
schwert eigentlich kann sollte jetzt
einfach drei von diesen sind relativ
schnell getötet ich kann damit fuhren
hier quasi direkt zwei schläge sagte
todt
und wer als besiegt und außerdem an
dieses schwert noch drei möglichkeiten
und zwar wenn ich jetzt wieder skelette
hinsetze und die mich jetzt abschließen
wollen und ich halte diese schwert
einfach in der hand und die treffen mich
nicht dann biete schon die pfeile die
daneben nehmen
mehr in drei verschiedene oder vier
verschiedene teile splitten werden
sondern einfach ein fall bleiben dann
wenn ich eine spinne hinsetze schießt
die keine spyder web beziehungsweise sie
schiebt noch welche aber sie kann sich
nicht direkt abschießen und wenn ich
einen zombie hinsetze und diesem töte
spot der auch keine riesen mehr was
willst du denn hier die ganze zeit das
sind eigentlich schon die hauptsachen
die ich euch zeigen wollte ich habe
versucht so kurz wie möglich zu fassen
ich bin in der raw datei bei 24 minuten
wir hatten ja schon lange keine commands
folge meldet wegen euch mal wieder das
intro und suchen wir mal wieder ein gern
raus und ich meine was gibt es für
besseren command als jemanden der wie
geile command schreibt er einen neuen
schwierigkeitsgrad in minecraft
hinzugefügt hat den höhlen command alles
wird viel krasser werden neue items neue
mops und ich hab gedacht ja man geiler
als e commerce feiert ich habe ein buch
geschrieben über minecraft acts und
commands sollte die mittlerweile wissen
wenn ihr wollt kauft der linken ist
nicht wollt dann kaufte sich ich meine
man kann die acht oder neun euro auf
jeden fall noch sehr gesundheitlich in
mehrere pizzen investieren das ist
natürlich auch möglich aber bevor ich
ihnen noch mehr scheiße laber und luca
nachher vier oder fünf stunden im
schnitt sitzt dann war es mit dem video
wenn es euch gefallen hat und ihr habt
mehr bock auf solche oldschool shit
sachen dann zeigt mir dass bewertung und
wir sehen uns dann vielleicht gar nicht
mehr wieder weil ich einfach ich bin gar
nicht mehr